wait did Otto Hightower really just say
that and why would he even suggest such
a thing here's the creepiest thing
that's happened in House of the Dragon
so far beware spoilers for episode 3
just ahead it is known that house of the
dragon and Game of Thrones have been
partly inspired by real life historical
events while at the same time being
filled to the brim with creepy and
awkward situations we suppose that is to
be expected though since real life
history has its fair share of bad
decisions as reported by BBC Author
George R.R Martin Drew heavily from the
real-life 14th century conflict known as
the Hundred Years War in the crafting of
his novels knowing that series Creator
Martin is a history buff and with fans
expecting a certain amount of scheming
viewers are probably watching the
actions of characters very closely
although there are no obvious
Littlefinger or Tywin Lannister types
yet certain actions from Otto Hightower
are starting to raise some red flags so
far we have seen Auto manipulate his own
young daughter into marrying King
viserys as well as antagon Damon
Targaryen but it seems as if Otto's
recent suggestion in episode 3 may be
the creepiest power grab of all time
episode 3 of House of the Dragon is
primarily focused on lines of succession
previously princess rhaenyra Targaryen
was named heir to the Seven Kingdoms by
her father King viserys after the death
of his newborn son and wife although
there has never been a queen in the
history of Westeros viserys is
determined that he made the right choice
unfortunately many of his subjects and
advisors openly question his decision
this issue of succession is compounded
even more when viserys marries Alison
and she gives birth to a male Heir named
aegon which apparently is an
exceptionally popular name among the
targaryens the child is assumed by the
realm to be the eventual new Heir so
much so that other Royal houses make
marriage proposals aimed at rhaenyra the
most insufferable proposal fans have
seen thus far has been that of Jason
Lannister who has all of the trademark
arrogance of others of the same last
name
thank you for the wine
though rhaenyra rebuffs Jason's advances
and even fights with her father over his
attempts to find her a suitable match
she declares that she doesn't want to
marry and just wants to be queen king
viserys then proclaims that as royalty
they are honor bound to tradition and
that they must marry to strengthen
Bloodlines in the lines of succession he
then adds that he will not force her
hand and that she can marry whomever she
chooses however that isn't an idea Auto
Hightower thinks is good and he has an
entirely different suggestion
Otto suggests that viserys betrothed
rhaenyra to aegon which should
immediately get viewers to recoil and
disgust as Otto honestly considers
having a half-sister and brother marry
each other this isn't unheard of in
Targaryen history as they have a
reputation for marrying family members
for the so-called preservation of a pure
bloodline this has been previously
mentioned by Cersei and Jaime Lannister
in Game of Thrones who Justified their
own relationship by referencing the
Targaryen tradition of marrying siblings
considering the political maneuvering of
Otto Hightower this makes sense as he
wants to strengthen his own grandson's
claim on the Iron Throne since there is
some debate as to who the heir will be
by marrying the two siblings there would
be one unified claim this isn't without
historical precedent as real-life Royal
marriage between blood relatives was
relatively common up until the onset of
World War One this practice perceived as
keeping Royal Blood pure often resulted
in rare genetic diseases and physical
abnormalities and was also of course
insanely gross as previously mentioned
the targaryens do have a habit of
marrying blood relatives and the realm
often suffers for it whatever his
reasons Otto should not be absolved for
making the suggestion the thought of it
is stomach turning although he seems to
have his sights on asserting control of
the Iron Throne he can also Relish in
his newly acquired award for creepiest
advice ever